hello everyone and welcome back to the
state of the web my guest today is adios
mati he's an engineering manager on the
chrome team focusing on web performance
and today's episode is all about
JavaScript it makes the web go round but
too much of it can actually be a bad
thing this is the state of JavaScript
let's get started Eddie thanks for much
bigger thank you for having me so how
long have you been doing web development
whoa way too long it's been about 17
years now and I understand that you used
to build your own browser is that true
yeah instead of learning web development
I decided to build a browser to
understand how browsers work so I like
built Senate supported like hates show
up are seeing in CSS and my path to
JavaScript was building like a very
small engine for understanding how it
works so back then what was the state of
JavaScript like was it just being used
as a toy for dhtml JavaScript was being
used for adding rainbows and sparkles to
your webpages it wasn't being used to
like build really complex apps and
that's kind of where we're at right now
in the post gmail era we're building
entirely complex applications sending
more and more JavaScript apps for users
so how do developers know if they have a
Java Script problem so building
interactive experiences on the web today
usually involves sending JavaScript down
to users often too much of it and the
impact that can have on the experience
is that if you're sending too much
JavaScript down that involves a CPU
having to spend a lot of time processing
it can take a very long time on mobile
devices if you're on a slower network
that can also mean it'll take a while
for that JavaScript to be downloaded the
way I like to think about measuring if
javascript is a problem for your site is
using a workflow that is you know
measure optimize and monitor so for
measuring if javascript is a problem I
recommend folks check out lighthouse
we've got a number of performance audits
in place there so go run the lighthouse
from the chrome developer tools it's
also supported on webpagetest and that
will give you some insight into you know
are you just sending way too much code
down to your users if you are it'll tell
you if javascript boot up time is an
issue and it'll also give you a few
ideas
around things that you can do to reduce
that amount of script now the reason why
javascript has got such a cost is that
there are a number of different steps a
browser has to take any order to process
it like if you know if you're loading up
a web page that JavaScript first of all
needs to be fetched over a network then
needs to be parsed by the browser
parsing can take a very long time a
slower CPU it has to be compiled and
then executed for many sites if you're
shipping Meg's and Meg's and mountains
worth of JavaScript down to users that
can take seconds and seconds of time and
that's not so uncommon in the HTTP
archive we've seen at the 90th
percentile sites are actually sending
more than a megabyte of JavaScript and
that's gzipped
and minified yeah so that's a lot of
code that's a lot of code that's so
that's yeah as you said that's minified
in gzip code we're saying you know
uncompressed is probably 2 or 3 times
that so a lot of people are you know
having a browser deal with Meg's of
JavaScript literally then has to process
just great yeah but the good news is
that the median is only only 400
kilobytes it's still a huge amount of
code but it's not in a megabytes luckily
so what guidance would you give to
developers to use JavaScript responsibly
throw it all out
no don't you can't you can't throw it
all so what I recommend doing is only
ship the code that you use your needs
for the current page or the current
route very often what sites will do is
they'll bundle all of their JavaScript
into one big monolithic glob and ship
that down instead of doing that what if
you broke it up in smaller pieces so
just rip the code needed for the current
page once that's fetched you can use
techniques like prefetching pre-caching
using a serviceworker
to go and start fetching in lazily
loading in the rest the code needed and
the benefit of that is the user can
start interacting with the spirit the
experience very early on and you know if
they go and start interacting with the
rest of the pages on the site you've had
an opportunity to you know get that code
into the cache and maybe a little bit
quicker so general try to do that the
technique that you'd use for that is
called code splitting it's a check
supported by lots of tools things like
wet pack and parcel support it it's
possible to code split using you know
things like react and view and angularjs
pre-act most popular frameworks support
this I would love to get to a point
where more frameworks are code splitting
by default or rather just encouraging
you to kind of shape your codes so
you're not going to be bundling
everything into a single file but code
splitting is the first big one
I think another thing you can do is take
advantage of techniques like tree
shaking so tree shaking although it
sounds a little violence is this idea of
removing unused you know imports in your
code so if I'm gonna be importing in a
library like a you know some piece of
you know UI maybe I'll mom importing in
bootstrap I'm importing is something
else I probably don't need everything
that it provides so tree shaking is this
idea of only including the imports that
you're actually using and stripping away
everything else to reduce that overall
amount of script and the experience
there are lots of other things we notice
like most of the sites that I trace will
include polyfills that are probably not
needed for modern browsers a common one
is people still polyfill JavaScript
promises you know promises have been
well supported for a number of years I
promise but I think that you know audit
the polyfills are shipping down checked
upon the weight of the libraries you're
importing one thing folks can do is use
tools like source map Explorer or web
pack bundle analyzer and what that'll do
is it'll give you this really pretty big
graph showing you okay well here's your
application logic here are all the
libraries that you're importing and by
the way maybe it'll highlight
opportunities to remove duplicate code
sometimes will like import things
multiple times by accident or
opportunities just like swap out the
libraries we're using for much smaller
ones a popular example is if you're
building an app that's working with
dates in anyway people we use moment yes
and the moment yes locales those have a
heavy weight so there's a couple hundred
kilobytes you could switch that out for
something like date FNS it's much
smaller still has the same
capabilities for the most part but keep
an eye on the cost of your script
because you know there are usually a few
things you can do to bring that size
down so I have to ask what is the state
of third parties in JavaScript maybe ads
in like their parties are an interesting
one so third parties have got this
reputation and and well-earned so of
like tanking web experience is quite
often and this is a particularly a
problem with publisher sites new sites I
would say that we often see a lot of
first party code still having a big
issue so as we increasingly start
building experiences using javascript
you know there's gonna be a balance of
like first party code being a big issue
third party code being a big issue for
third party code it's really important
to first of all again audit the impact
of those experiences there is a chance
that you know maybe your site is using
an ad network of some sort maybe you
don't have as much control for the type
of content they're gonna pull in what I
would do there is just take a look at
whether there are options for you to
lazy load some of those frames some of
those embeds so that you know the users
are not paying for the cost of them when
they're just like loading up the site we
are exploring a few ideas in chrome at
the moment try helping with this things
like adding support for lazy loading to
the platform for images and iframes
I'm hopeful that that that will help I'm
hopeful that future ideas like feature
policy where you can like sort of
control what a third-party can do will
also help a little bit here and in
general just try to audit those third
parties as much as possible and check if
they actually are providing value to the
site in in the case that you're trying
to nail down okay well what specific
third-party is responsible for a lot of
scripts the chrome dev tools actually
have support for this feature called
third-party badging so if you go and
record a new profile using the
performance panel open up the page take
a look at your trace what it will say is
these are all of the different sort of
brands or companies who have loaded up
third-party scripts in your site you can
then go and organize it sort of bottom
up or
or why different ways of visualizing the
data and say okay well who has actually
been spending a lot of time in script
and figure out are there are there ways
for me to send feedback back to those ad
providers or options for me to evaluate
if I could switch out my providers to
somebody else that isn't gonna tank
performance quite as much so assuming a
developer can improve their JavaScript
and their web performance how can they
ensure that they can stay fast because
regressions happen requirements are
changing the more they touch their code
the less likely it is that it's going to
stay fast yeah absolutely I think as an
industry we need to shift towards
adopting performance budgets something
that I commonly see is you know an
engineering team will get really psyched
about improving their performance
they'll do a sprint where they try to
make things better and they'll celebrate
those wins come back a quarter or later
and suddenly everything is on fire and
the reason for that is often that we're
not enforcing budgets for you know how
well we are agreeing as an organization
that the experience has to be we need to
get to a place where like you know sites
have agreed on you know maybe not
shipping more than 170 kilobytes of
minified inches of JavaScript for their
experiences whatever number makes sense
to keep your time too interactive you
know in a good place but once you have
those budgets in place it can be
enforced at a continuous integration
level so you know if I'm an engineer
working on a new feature and I submit
that to my team hopefully you know in
Travis or something else they'll be able
to see in the pull request okay well the
cost of this feature was so and so and
it has or hasn't broken the budget and
if it has broken the budget I think that
that's an opportunity to empower sort of
project managers to make a call on you
know is this feature we're adding
actually worth it to the impact it's
going to have on the performance of the
site and the user experience
I feel like today maybe we aren't giving
PMS quite as much data needed to make
those types of calls so there's there's
an amount of work we need to do on the
engineering side on the PM side I also
think that we need to do an amount of
work to get just businesses to
understand the value of
adopting performance cultures and
keeping those budgets in place because
as you mentioned like regression
analysis is something that's kind of
it's missing right now you do a lot more
there for folks that want to adopt
performance budgets for their sites I'm
happy to recommend checking out
lighthouse sea I also happy to recommend
checking out speed curve or caliber
these are third-party solutions but they
have support for setting performance
budgets based on sort of a metrics level
or a size level and they'll give you
sort of alerting capabilities as well so
if your team happened to you know work
on new features and they break your
JavaScript budget you know you can start
getting alerts in the middle of the
night saying hey fix it which is
slightly better than the situation we've
got today are there any changes browser
vendors could do on like the web dev
tool inside yes absolutely so it's it's
a really tricky problem to solve right
because a browser isn't just going to
completely disable JavaScript for
everybody that would that would break a
lot of the web what we can do is take
into account you know different
heuristics so if you are on say a
effectively slow 2g network and we don't
think that there's a chance you would
have otherwise been able to view any
content one of the sort of interventions
we're exploring is this idea of
disabling JavaScript's at least for a
preview of the experience so maybe we
just show you you know initially the
site without JavaScript allow you to see
some content make a call on you know is
this actually the thing I was looking
for and if you want you know we'll show
you like a little info bar at the very
bottom of the screen so you can view the
original site and the original content
if you'd like but hoping to give people
a slightly better user experience at the
end of the day now these types of
interventions are something we're very
careful about trying to make sure that
as much as possible it's only gonna be
explored for sites that we know are
probably going to be able to function
without that much JavaScript to place
but we're exploring some ideas I think
there's definitely a lot more other
browsers can do in this space
well addy thank you so much for being
here I'm gonna go check out your browser
and compare benchmarks on JavaScript to
see how that
Paris to Chrome today the answer is it's
gonna be awful measure the cost of your
JavaScript and try to figure out that's
a problem for users so we're gonna have
links to everything we talked about in
the description lighthouse web page test
click on those measure your JavaScript
and stay fast thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]